i love the honesty in the book hey i
look at instagram i look at pictures of
other women i look at the pictures of
myself i try to see if i look really
good this is this is who you are and and
what your job really was
so you get pregnant are you freaking out
are you saying to yourself every minute
my god my body's changing i'm known for
my body i make a living with my body i
sell bathing suits i sell everything
under the sun because of my body i got
famous because of it and now
am i going to be able to snap back so to
speak i remember after you had the baby
every picture was like has she snapped
back yet you know it was like yeah did
she get well and then she lose her body
people were really angry um
there was a you know i posted some like
video and pajamas that my company had
just launched and
um
i like had a doc there was a dockatot
which is like what a baby lays in um
behind me and i said like oh excuse the
dockatot or something and all these
there was one woman particularly um who
has like a small following but she was
so mad um
and she was like oh excuse the doc
attack like she wants us to know that
she snapped back this is unrealistic
pressure blah blah
um and you know i just feel like i don't
have to share every part of my life um
there are you know i even i posted
pictures of me and in labor that are
super personal um that my husband took
on film
and i was like you know
felt crazy looked crazy they were the
pictures that i liked from from
whatever but i just feel like okay i
don't have to share every step of my
journey
but i you know put on these pajamas
thought i looked all right and took a
video and it really upset um a lot of
people but that was my experience um
and listen my body is different i have a
little bit of extra skin still and you
know whatever um but i didn't freak out
when i was pregnant because um
i think that being pregnant helped me
appreciate my body in a new way that i
had never uh i had never thought of my
body i loved being pregnant it was
definitely there were days where i woke
up and was like terrified because
you know you just are completely out of
control you're and and control such a
big thing for me and
um i didn't have control my my body was
just changing and there's this you know
not only my life but this little baby's
life you know on the line and i'm like
thinking like what's gonna happen to to
to my stomach to everything
but because
it was blowing my mind that my body was
taking care of another life and mine so
much that it actually
kind of made me appreciate the the way
my body can be outside of like the way
it looks in any way